kendall Jenner ranks her nieces and  nephews names from best to worst  that's so weird to me  the 21 year old reality star was a guest  on The Late Late Show with James Corden  on Wednesday where she subjected herself  to the game spill your guts or fill your  guts or James and Kendall go back and  forth asking one another questions if  they aren't willing to answer they have  to eat something terrible Kendall  three of your nieces and nephews unnamed  dream north and saints rank those baby  names from best to worst  we considering it like say like  answering and she did North st. dream  but one question the model wouldn't  answer who is your least favorite member  of Taylor Swift's squad  according to James  Kendall's sister Kylie was supposed to  be a guest on the show the called in  sick the day before to cancel here's  what happened when James called her out  in epic fashion his  so my question is how's she feeling  don't smell it  you